in the Russian Capital Moscow the
reaction to the strikes across Ukraine
has been mixed
it's an answer to terrorists who
destroyed the bridge it was civilian
infrastructure no mercy for terrorists
no it's not right you can't want
peaceful cities
our patients has limits the Crimean
Bridges Russian infrastructure and
ukrainians also have that kind of
infrastructure
I feel very sorry that innocent people
are dying but if they are Precision
strikes then it's all right
we should have done it sooner because
it's an answer to aggression
I don't know it's a military question
you need to ask them we follow what's
going on but don't understand what's
happening
all right let's talk now to DW Russia
analyst Constantine Eggert for more he's
in the Lithuanian Capital Vilnius
Constantine great to see you so clearly
divided opinions there how do you think
the last few days have affected support
for the War uh within Russia
well I don't think you can speak about
supports or decrease and supports
um at such short notice uh one thing for
sure is that uh when Putin announced uh
partial mobilization which turns out to
be I think pretty much General on the
21st of September he brought this war
into the Russians living rooms before
that that was just war on television uh
in the evening now it is going to affect
more and more people over time so the
Crimean bridge that was of course a very
uh a very very significant PR style for
Ukraine but you know as as you see from
the answers and I think they're pretty
pretty much reflecting the attitude
people just do not realize that it's
Russia attacking Ukraine that the Crimea
wasn't Russian and it is it was
and annexation eight years ago so I
think we're dealing with a public
opinion which still refuses to face
reality and it will take time and I'm
afraid really a lot of coffins and a lot
of injured before this opinion starts to
change
well that actually was bringing me on to
my next question because we're seeing
civilians essentially have been targeted
and do you not think that could turn the
tide against Vladimir Putin
um in Russia
human Ukrainian civilians yeah Ukrainian
civilians but you don't think that it
would affect um the attitude that
Russians have towards uh Putin at home
no I don't think so I think that those
who were against this war
um are pretty much
I they are the god they are the left
Russia or they already set in their ways
those who support the war will continue
to support it there is this huge middle
in Russia and there's going to be a
battle for this medal and I think so far
the Kremlin managed to ignite flames of
hatred uh flames of uh uh really huge
xenophobic attitude towards ukrainians
and uh this idea that ukrainians are
attacking Russians on their land that is
what the Kremlin is now trying to push
down the down rush of throats millions
of Russian Thrones and I think to some
extent they will succeed alas so I think
that before public opinion changes
before it starts to see
um
Ukrainian victims as really victims uh
there will be time and during this time
we'll see more victims on both sides
there's no doubt that Ukraine will
continue resisting and it will continue
striking Russian targets so in a sense
uh we are now talking about a situation
in which probably those who are really
interested in the situation are even
more set in their ways at least inside
Russia
DW's Constantine Eggert in Vilnius thank
you
thank you
I'm joined Now by Vitali Kim he's the
regional governor of mikolai in
Southeastern Ukraine thanks for joining
us here on DW so tell us how badly has
your region been hit by today's strikes
hello everybody
um you know for the luck our region
wasn't hit too hard today we have 10
missiles attacked in the night everybody
is okay we have no victims and one
missile we have in region in region
Belize
our military forces strike heated 14
missiles on the territory on the
territory of agnikov region so not so
bad but we're comparing it to the seven
months and so for before it so for today
it is okay because our infrastructure is
not damaged our people is not killed in
our region so it's okay
well Vladimir Putin says the strikes are
retaliation for the weekend bombing of
the Kirsch bridge to Crimea but in fact
actually the Ukrainian Military
Intelligence is saying that they were
planned beforehand what's your reaction
to that
I think that
this attack is this is demonstration of
weakness of Russian army because they
understood that they are losing their
position and losing their position not
only the battlefield but in the whole
world so this is demonstration of a
weakness there are cowards they are
taking civilian people and critical
infrastructure before the winter so I
think it's not a Revenge but it's just
demonstration of weakness now he's also
threatened a heart response to further
Ukrainian attacks how worried are you
about the nuclear threat from Russia
you know he's losing so he need to say
something uh well me personally not
worry about this situation it is bad for
our infrastructure and for civilian
people because they
like our intelligence says there was
planning it before and they had such a
plan many months ago but they realized
and started to plan to plan it directly
in the beginning of the month
so we are prepared for any
um
any situation the Ukraine is United
very much for now we have the best
president and we have no right to stand
to step back so Ukraine is Pretty Tough
so tough so we are not worried well
since Saturday Russia has a new
Commander for its operation in Ukraine
how do you think that'll affect Russia's
military tactics
once again what new Commander
um there was at the new Commander Sergey
pseudo vegan
uh I don't think that it will affect any
no way it will affect our situation the
battlefield because they changed already
many commanders in different directions
I think it will change nothing because
Russian army is very um
corrupt and weak and they have no
motivation the the occupants they're
fighting on the land of uh neighborhood
countries so the Russians started to
realize that they have no purpose they
have no goals in Ukraine so it will
change nothing in my opinion
Vitali Kim the regional governor of
mikolai thank you for joining us on DW
are you welcome
let's speak now to Andrea in Kiev he's a
member of the Ukrainian Parliament for
the opposition voice party welcome to DW
so what can you tell us about the
targets that were hit today Russia says
it was actually targeting Key Energy and
military command facilities
um good evening if it's good evening uh
I'm not sure that everyone is familiar
with the geography of q but I recently
had a discussion with one journalist
from United Kingdom and I told him so if
to have to make any parallel with with
London for example so the places of
attack in Kiev today was something like
Hyde Park Corner in London meaning that
it's actually The Heart of the City it's
a park zone of the city it just next to
two University buildings and to the
University Library whereby the way I was
studying years ago so it is absolutely
Central peaceful residential area of the
capital of Ukraine which has for the
moment about I think 2.5 almost 3
million people inside regular civilians
who was just on the street were killed
so regular civilian cars was burned and
it is definitely
Act of terrorism based on international
law so if we respect any rules of
international order and if you respect
the international law we shall be very
very clear it was
an act of terrorism of international and
the act of international crime
tell us what effect these strikes are
having on the Ukrainian people
uh from a technological point of view if
you allow me to say so the the strike
was quite extended as your journalists
already reported so more than 80
missiles are very very different type
has been launched on Ukraine about 50
percent or something little bit more was
shut down but the rest arrived to
different cities of Ukraine and yes I
can confirm that some infrastructure
objects were were damaged especially
electricity uh mostly damage was the
Western Ukraine again as you reported in
the view kill you for the moment I'm
speaking to you from my apartment in the
city center so all the electricity hot
water everything is operating very well
from another site the target of Vladimir
Putin was again to make us afraid he is
repeating the same logic as he did in
February 24 because the original plan
was to make a scary and make us run away
but we we are still alive simply because
we are not afraid and we fight and I
believe that this missile attacks is
another signal for Ukrainian Society to
be even more Consolidated to fight and I
hope that all our allies will understand
these attacks on the same way we shall
be much more Consolidated because
depending on this consolidation the
duration of this War uh depends so we
shall finish this as fast as possible
because as you see every day is a life
of innocent people
now how do you view Vladimir Putin's
claim that these strikes are actually in
retaliation for the attack on the Kirsch
bridge to Crimea which Russia has blamed
on Ukraine because actually Ukraine is
saying that these attacks could have
been planned before that incident
Putin is in very very complex situation
because two days ago
the most protected
sexual object in Russia was exploded
and I'm sure that with an attack of
Ukraine today's attack on Ukraine he's
saving his reputation in the eyes of his
gangster's team because there were
threatening US during weeks but everyone
understand that Crimea bridge and Crimea
is the diamonds in the crown of his
dictatorship and the fact that the
bridge was exploded dramatically
influenced reputation of Putin inside of
his country so today he was showing to
his friends to his billionaires that he
still can act and he still can defend
his interest but I'm sure that inside of
the Russia there are huge problems in
leadership and I still think that very
soon this story can be ended very
unexpectedly because majority of Putin's
so-called friends they are not Shahid
they want to live long and happy life
with their billions of dollars and what
Putin is now doing is absolutely
opposite to their plans
tell us briefly if you could now the
French President Emmanuel macron says
that these strikes signal a profound
change in the war how should the West
respond
first of all there is no big uh surprise
for us everyone who is watching this
program shall remember that for seven
months a draw Russia was selling
Ukrainian citizens and Villages some
cities and Villages just keys to exist
so that's why it was not a surprise for
the West
shall be very simple Russian economy and
Russia shall be switched off from Global
markets because as long as we're
fighting with the arms and with our
people the West shall fight with
economical sanctions sanctions shall be
tough and real that's the way how we
shall speed up the victory in this war
Andre osachuk member of the Ukrainian
Parliament thank you for joining us on
DW